Traduttore: Silvia Fornasiero
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Oggi vi voglio parlare di città.
Vi voglio parlare di città
e soprattutto del futuro
che queste città possono raggiungere
nel momento in cui decidono
di superare questa stagione ambigua
in cui la politica forse
ha perso sicurezza,
sicuramente denaro,
ma anche forza ideale;
in cui la stampa, aih noi,
cerca spesso solo notizie decotte;
in cui i pessimisti urlano
più forte degli ottimisti.
Ve ne voglio parlare perché
io sono invece convinto
che sia in corso in Italia
e non in Europa
una vera e propria primavera urbana,
che fa piazza pulita degli schemi classici
e mette pubblico e privato finalmente
a negoziare dalla stessa parte del tavolo.
Ci aiuta in questo una frase
di Alejandro Aravena.
Voi sapete Alejandro ha vinto
il premio Nobel dell'architettura
ed è il più giovane vincitore
del premio Nobel dell'architettura
quest'anno.
Alejandro chiude il proprio Ted talk
nel 2014 dicendo:
"Il potere della progettazione
è cercare di fare un uso più efficiente
delle risorse scarse nelle città.
E questo non è un fatto di soldi
ma di coordinamento".
Ebbene io mi occupo di paesaggio urbano;
ma cosa significa?
Non significa disegnare
nuovi filari di alberi,
ma cercare di ricostruire
un immaginario coordinato
per fare città facendo comunità.
Credo di aver capito questo
una notte, esattamente
una notte di 40 anni fa.
Pensate, il sei maggio 1976
intere città crollavano in Friuli
su intere comunità.
E mentre lì la natura
faceva mille morti,
io al tempo vivevo a Vittorio Veneto
e fui costretto
a girare la città di notte,
a fermarmi nei parcheggi,
lungo una strada,
in tanti piccoli luoghi della città.
Ebbene, quell'immaginario
mi aveva fatto capire
che spesse volte città e comunità
si danno le spalle.
Veniamo ad oggi.
Che cosa sta succedendo?
Oggi sta succedendo, invece,
che città e comunità hanno
tre grandi moschettieri
che gli consentono di tornare insieme.
Il primo è la crisi,
lo conosciamo.
Il secondo è una legge cometa
che arriva dall'Europa;
legge in Italia da dieci anni
ma ancora molto inascoltata.
Si chiama
Convenzione Europea del Paesaggio.
Il terzo è ovviamente una frase di Proust.
La crisi, ho detto, la conosciamo.
La seconda, la legge cometa,
dice ad un certo punto una frase
che manda in soffitta
quattrocento anni di storia.
La frase è: "È un paesaggio
un qualunque pezzo di territorio
trasformato con consapevolezza".
Improvvisamente il paesaggio
non è più solo il bel paesaggio.
Lo aveva già detto in modo diverso Proust
tempo addietro.
Proust aveva detto:
"Il vero viaggio di scoperta non significa
andare a visitare nuove terre,
ma sostanzialmente, semplicemente
avere nuovi occhi."
Ebbene, con questi tre moschettieri
non abbiamo più alibi
e quindi, abbiamo capito
che siamo infilati in un bel tunnel,
ma abbiamo tutti gli strumenti
per poter finalmente arredare un tunnel.
Veniamo ai temi di oggi.
A tutti voi sarà capitato
di cominciare a schiacciare play
sul mangianastri analogico,
anche, immagino,
i nativi digitali in sala.
Ebbene, non era tanto il problema
che questo tasto
non si riuscisse a schiacciare,
quanto il fatto che sotto casa
non c'era più il negozio
che poteva aggiustarvelo.
Nel frattempo il negozio
era stato sostituito
da una rivendita di cover per smartphone.
Bere, immaginate che alle città
stia accadendo esattamente questo:
i decisori schiacciano play
ma quel play non sta più giù.
Ci troviamo a vivere da vintage urbani,
da hipster nostalgici.
Che cosa è accaduto?
È accaduto che è venuta giù
quella Babele speculativa
nella quale un impresario edile
in una notte diventava
imprenditore immobiliare.
È accaduto che interi quartieri
avanzassero sotto i nostri occhi
con il piede gonfio,
lo stesso piede gonfio di quel ministro
che se ne è andato
lasciandoci una legge
sui capannoni ovunque
e a un certo punto una frase:
"Con la cultura non si mangia".
Potete immaginare quale fu
a mia soddisfazione
di togliermi un sassolino dalla scarpa,
un giorno di ferragosto,
e di spiegare esattamente
a quell'omonimo signor T.
che io non ero d'accordo con lui,
ma aderivo invece alla frase --
scusate --
alla frase del grande geografo
Franco Farinelli che dice:
"La cultura è l'ultimo grande
manipolatore di senso che ci resta".
Ebbene, quella frase consentì
a me personalmente di fare due azzardi
che cambiarono integralmente la mia vita
all'incirca nel 2007.
Il primo infinitamente piccolo:
una parola;
il secondo infinitamente grande:
un festival.
Il primo mi consentì di proporre
al dibattito a cui già appartenevo
un termine.
Il termine era casannone,
casa più capannone.
E riusciva a descrivere molto più
di qualunque saggio
quell'epopea che aveva trasformato
il nord-est negli ultimi 50 anni.
Quella forza mi veniva,
non dai soliti libri
nei quali un paesaggista
si andava a formare,
'Le Città Invisibili' piuttosto che
'Le sei passeggiate nei boschi narrativi'
di Umberto Eco.
Mi derivava da un carteggio tra due amici,
un carteggio nel quale i due amici
si scambiavano delle cartoline
con all'interno dei casi tipologici
assolutamente curiosi:
la chiesa multiuso
piuttosto che la campacasa.
Avevo capito la grande forza
dello storytelling.
Un secondo azzardo che feci
fu quello di lanciare in Italia nel 2007
il primo festival dedicato
alle aree dismesse.
Una piattaforma nata dal basso come TEDx,
per rompere completamente gli schemi,
per ibridare le discipline.
È una piattaforma nella quale
improvvisamente
c'era la possibilità di realizzare
degli interi giardini abusivi;
c'era perfino la possibilità
di mettere il pigiama
e di trasformare
la piazza centrale della città
in una grande camera da letto.
C'era perfino la possibilità
di portare a scala urbana
quel gesto che tutti noi
almeno una volta abbiamo fatto,
cioè quello di mettere un elastico
tra le mani e cominciare a fare così.
Bene, immaginate che cosa possa accadere
se questo gesto assume
la dimensione urbana.
Accade quello che ora vedete.
(Nel video: Comodamente 2013
7 tappe di una parata
lunga 8.252 passi e 24 ore)
(Nel video: L'Italia vista dalla luna
e quindi anche la moda in Italia
vista dalla luna)
Bene, appunto, l'Italia vista dalla luna.
Io penso che l'Italia sia in curva,
o meglio, oltre quella curva
esiste già un immaginario di città
che ci consenta di mandare in soffitta
un'altra frase.
Tutti noi diciamo sempre
e pensiamo di capire la storia
per riuscire ad agire nel presente.
E invece io penso che oggi noi dobbiamo
capire il presente per capire la storia.
Abbiamo capito che finalmente
soluzione complessa e soluzione semplice
non sono più
in contraddizione tra di loro.
E con tutto questo bagaglio,
vorrei farvi vedere due progetti
e un immaginario di progetto
che sta nascendo
esattamente proprio nella vostra città.
Il primo progetto che vi faccio vedere
è un progetto che lanciò
il più grande investitore altoatesino,
un grandissimo collezionista
di arte contmporanea.
Lui cerca, si compra
il più grande magazzino dismesso
delle Ferrovie dello Stato
che affaccia sull'Adige.
Si immagina di poter realizzare
il suo business in brevissimo tempo.
Ma anche lui, nonostante fosse
alimentato dalle sue visioni,
sbatte di fronte a quel muro di gomma
che tutti noi abbiamo vissuto
almeno una volta;
quel muro di gomma si chiama burocrazia.
Allora che cosa bisogna fare?
Dovevamo trovare una mossa del cavallo,
mettere una zeppa, scartare appunto.
Ci siamo riusciti passando
da un progetto
a un programma molto più complesso
che innanzitutto decidesse di accettare
quel luogo così come trovato.
Il primo gesto, quindi, significativo
non fu quello di disegnare appartamenti,
ma immediatamente
di fare un'operazione di questo tipo:
tirare giù il muro
che divideva quello spazio
dal quartiere popolare
di Porto San Pancrazio
e di realizzare in soli quattro giorni
uno spazio da mettere
a disposizione della comunità.
Uno spazio che non aveva panchine,
che aveva dei disegni
che riprendevano le regole dei campi
del parco rurale che ci stava di fianco,
uno spazio in cui mettere in scena
pezzi dell'arte contemporanea
della collezione di quell'imprenditore.
E nei mesi successivi l'imprenditore
fu subissato di richieste
per utilizzare questo spazio
prima di tutto dalla propria comunità.
Non aveva ancora realizzato
un solo appartamento.
Il secondo esempio che vi faccio vedere
fa riferimento a un paese
nel quale ognuno di voi almeno una volta
ha pensato di andarci.
Sto parlando di Collodi,
il paese di Pinocchio,
il secondo libro più tradotto al mondo
dopo la Bibbia.
Un paese compreso
tra una valle delle cartiere
che da sola assorbe gran parte
del fabbisogno nazionale
della carta in Italia
e quindi è ovvio che quella favola
non poteva non essere che scritta lì,
e a sud una grande valle
di serre dei fiori.
Voi mi direte, con la carta e con i fiori
Collodi dev'essere un paese straordinario.
E invece no. Bugia.
Collodi è una delle periferie più tristi
e sconosciute che voi possiate trovare.
Perché accade questo?
Accade perché anche a Collodi
quelle che noi chiamiamo
centralità antibiotiche,
i musei, la piazza,
il monumento dedicato a Collodi
che cercano i turisti,
non dialoga più con le centralità
che chiamiamo omeopatiche
e che sono parte
della quotidianità dei cittadini:
la discesa al fiume, una piazza
che nel frattempo è diventata parcheggio
e si è degradata
e tanti altri luoghi minori.
Insomma, dovevamo cercare uno strumento
che ci consentisse di mettere insieme
queste due centralità.
Lo abbiamo trovato ridisegnando
e guardate cosa siamo riusciti a trovare.
Siamo riusciti a capire che esisteva
un parco più ampio
in cui centralità antibiotiche
e omeopatiche si mettevano insieme
e assumevano perfino
il volto di Pinocchio,
in cui quella che era
la piazza dei turisti
in realtà diventava il centro del paese
e questo bosco era in realtà
un grande palazzo verde.
Vorrei chiudere
con una proiezione di progetto,
dicevo, appunto, a Vicenza.
A Vicenza abbiamo un luogo immenso
che ormai è nella bocca di tutti
ma in realtà è un luogo che ancora resta
sostanzialmente sconosciuto.
Questo luogo noi lo chiamiamo
il Parco della Pace.
Ebbene, vorrei dirvi da co-progettista
di quel luogo,
ma anche da cittadino acquisito
in questa città da pochi anni,
che non vi è dubbio che in quel luogo
oggi passino il cardo e il decumano
di una nuova comunità,
quella che si può realizzare
con i termini di prima.
Questo luogo può diventare
un nuovo Heimat,
si direbbe, una piccola patria.
Tutto sta nel saper veicolare, diciamo,
questa forza.
Bene, grazie a questi progetti,
io credo a questo punto di aver capito
e di proporre a voi questa cosa:
l'ibridazione dei saperi rappresenta
un giacimento illimitato
da cui estrarre nuove città
e nuovi paesaggi.
Tutto però dipende da quanto la comunità,
cioè voi e noi,
decide di tornare al centro della scena.
Grazie.